je dois vous dire que j'ai beaucoup de
problèmes avec les monty python minutes
please
j'ai beaucoup de problèmes avec les
monty python je savais qu il était
capable de tout faire sur un plateau de
télévision
ok jazz the day ok voilà je vais en
profiter pour vous les présentez vous
avez peut-être vu au cinéma dans leur
film sacré graal il ya terry gillian y
attache ni la menace eric idle minutes
ok ok c'est bien ok d'accord bon alors
les monty python plus en plus à oui je
suis sûr que ça va plaire bon alors je
vais essayer les compagnons je vous
présente pas les monty python qui sont
cinq ou six je crois universitaire très
cheap frais qui sont sortis des
universités de cambridge et d'oxford
avant de venir d'immenses vedette de la
bbc est également de la télévision
américaine
on parlera avec eux tout à l'heure je
vais essayer pour l'instant en placer
une pour vous dire pour vous dire que ce
que vous venez d'entendre et un hommage
bien sûr à la grande edith et je vous
dit tout à l'heure que fred mella a
chanté cette chanson avec d'autant plus
de conviction avec tous ses camarades
que c'est son fils qui a qui a écrit
cette chanson en partie faux le signal
est ou non oui en effet c'est mon fils
qui a écrit en collaboration avec un des
camarades pascal du phare qui est un
très bon musicien et ils ont été très
très emballé par le personnage d'edith
piaf c'est pour ça qu'ils ont voulu leur
rendre lui rendre hommage
vous restez en notre compagnie je
voudrais également ajouté que en
surimpression rémy graba qui a eu la
bonne idée de mettre des images d'une
émission dans ris pas que personne n'a
oublié c'était la joie de vivre
attendent encore une seconde
oui juste trente secondes pour annoncer
monte cristo la comédie musicale signée
michel legrand toute la troupe est sur
le plateau monte cristo